boa tarde para ser diferente eu trouxe
meu banco
para começar eu gostaria de dar um
rápido a introdução de que eu tenho sido
abordado muitas vezes para contar um
pouco como é que é o processo sucessório
numa empresa familiar que eu digo
essa pergunta me tem sido feita com uma
frequência enorme e eu pretendo
discorrer um pouquinho sobre isso o
tempo é escasso mas eu vou tentar fazer
para que eu possa fazer isso eu preciso
fazer uma rápida passada na história
para que vocês entendam um bom espero
conseguir tudo começa em 1938 quando
meus pais urina da alemanha nazista e
tiveram que sair correndo
no último minuto quase que antes um
pouquinho antes da noite dos cristais e
conseguir embarcar no navio que acho que
não foi uma escolha que foi embarcar e
veio depois quando ele vai e conseguiram
embarcar nesse navio que se dirigia à
buenos aires
esse navio fez uma escala no recife para
abastecimento e eles puderam descer e aí
então acontece a primeira coisa que
quase surda minha mãe principalmente
porque depois de 15 dias de ver água dos
dois lados
céu azul e água dois anos descem no
recife
acho que vocês conhecem o porto no
centro antigo e aí reparam que uma porta
sim uma não há sim uma não tinha uma
estrela de davi
a estrela de davi nada mais é do que o
símbolo do judaísmo
minha mãe quase surta neste país que eu
quero viver porque na alemanha a porta
da casa deles era pintada com uma
suástica a identificar que eram judeus e
ficou isso não uma cabeça sem dirando
quase não conseguiram entrar na rua até
que descobrir o que é
alguém de vocês sabe que é isso que foi
isso ainda é lembre-se não é é um
símbolo da cervejaria antarctica é
verdade é verdade
a antártica todos os produtos tinham no
seu rótulo uma estrela de davi um
azulzinho no meio você pode checar isso
na internet está lá
minha mãe quase surda não é bom
passado esse momento esclareceu se isso
pela chapa que era uma porta de casa de
judeus nada agora na antártica cerveja
antarctica etc bom e com getúlio naquela
época era o ditador brasileiro é ele não
permitiu que os refugiados alemães
entrassem então navio zarpou pra buenos
aires
lá eles conseguiram desembarcar tudo
direitinho e minha mãe foi operário
manga uma tecelagem meu pai levava às 5
horas da manhã para mexer numa máquina
ela nunca tinha visto mas tudo bem
e aí foram no consulado brasileiro e
foram plate ao visto em fazer a papelada
de ter visto e acho que uns seis meses
eu não sei precisar quando há cerca de
seis meses depois eles obtiveram um o
visto para vir para o brasil porque
queriam vir para o brasil acho que por
várias razões
quiseram vir para são paulo porque era
cidade onde a maioria dos que fugiram
via é só para ilustrar um pouco minha
mãe vai para a quebrada pelo cônsul
brasileiro e ele prometeu visto em amã
com o encontro num dia em que ele
concedeu visto diz ela dizia ela que
está esperando até hoje bom chegarão no
brasil
em 39 eu já sou meio no brasil
nasci em são paulo sou feito aqui e pela
guerra plena segunda guerra
meu pai arranjou um bico de
representante comercial da indústria de
confecção ele saía vendendo camisas capa
será a indústria
não faz ea coisa começou a apertar
porque tiveram dois filhos a mim meu
irmão e em 1947 e é preciso ajudar meu
pai de alguma forma
aí ela teve a ideia que nasceu
decorrente do convívio com os alemães em
são paulo de que os alemães pediram que
o senhor não acha um livro para ler um
mês ela a gente ouve falar no seu que
minha mãe teve a idéia de comprar dez
livros de um importador é irmão de e
livros da alemanha e deu crédito pra
minha mãe minha mãe comprou dez livros
diferentes hoje na sala e começou a
alugar como se fazia ou se faz ainda com
um vídeo com os vídeos da mesma maneira
trazer uma semana alugava os livros eram
bem acabados
então ela pode começou a ter uma pequena
receita dessa locação
as pessoas gostavam que iriam aí
começaram a estimular a minha mãe e eu
gostei tanto desse livro porque senão
com nosso comprar um quadro de presente
para minha tia será anos ouvindo isso
tal ideia também de começar a vender
livros
então na realidade neste momento nasce a
livraria tem tanto até então era uma
biblioteca circulante aí não cabiam mais
os livros em casa tiveram que mudar
nós estamos todos moramos juntos os
livros em nós né ai mãe e dois irmãos
aí foram para a rua augusta lá perto
razoavelmente perto num primeiro momento
dividindo uma loja depois deu briga
entre a minha mãe é sócio
aí fomos uma outra casa um sobrado que a
gente culpou o primeiro andar inteiro
que era bastante grande ea biblioteca ea
pequena livraria se instalar na sala era
grande e nós morávamos no fundo depois
que eu tive que optar em dormir na cama
ou no chão porque tinha livro para tudo
controlado conseguiram mudar para o
apartamento ao lado ea coisa se expandir
foi por quarto para a sala de certa isso
já estou falando de 57 por que eu tenho
que ser breve e meu pai continuava na
atividade dele
minha mãe ea cuidar da cozinha serve os
dois filhos pequenos
meu pai víamos a em casa quando o pai
vinha almoçar em casa minha mãe saía
correndo pra cozinha pra fazer comida
pra gente e eu estava voltando da escola
aquelas coisas aquele horário de almoço
eu me lembro uma vez ele contando e hoje
até presenciei um pouco disso vou contar
só que engraçado havia saído no fim da
década de 50 um
eu acho que é isso mas é por aí
é um livro do fritz khan que era sobre a
nossa vida sexual entre uma mulher e é
um livro de educação sexual
nada mais do que isso e essa mulher
entrou em meu pai ficava lá na frente da
na sala esperando algum eventual quente
enquanto minha mãe fazer um uso
ela perguntou desse livro que chamava se
nossa vida sexual
meu pai o alemão que mal falava
português abre a porta do corredor no
corredor desse tamanho e com essa escada
lá no fundo da cozinha estava minha mãe
e ele berra no fundo toda emfa nós têm
relações sexuais é verdade aconteceu por
macias crise e fez uma crônica naquela
ocasião a zero hora sobre isso
então essas coisas pitorescas
aconteceram durante toda a instalação da
família reta aqui no brasil foram coisas
muito engraçadas
o espaço ficou pequeno nós mudamos a
conteira e chega a década de 60
as coisas vão aumentando as coisas vão
crescendo
minha mãe vislumbra mudar pra avenida
paulista fim da década de 60 com
incidentemente quase coincidente mente
eu me caso
e nós mudamos pra avenida paulista nesse
minuto neste momento nesse minuto é o
centro na livraria
eu faço parte e conversamos um pouco
minha mãe ficou com muito medo despesas
com domínio imposto luz telefone todas
aquelas coisas será que a gente consegue
falar não fazer uma coisa é trabalhar e
se eu tiver ficar sem comer eu fico
entende mas não podemos ter funcionários
que não recebo isso muito bem
então a coisa continuou a coisa foi foi
andando deu certo começou a andar década
de 60
aí eu percebi já havia atritos entre nós
na sucessão dos meus pais e eu faria
começa neste momento tão já estou
falando da 1ª subseção de uma das
sessões na realidade eu vou falar um
pouquinho sobre sucessão
então eu comecei a dizer eu estava
desconfortável com o dinheiro que ficava
na gaveta
aí eu comprei um cofre de uma firma que
mudou lado do prédio
minha mãe ficou falando uma semana que
absurdo gastar esse dinheiro e comprei
um bebê x também sabe que o pbx o
negócio telefônico que precisava nos
últimos três linhas telefônicas um
negócio que a gente chegava e atende a
linha atende aqui minha mãe ficou num
discurso a gente começou há quase se
pegar mas resolvido acalmei ela viu que
tinha todo o sentido não tinha sentido o
dinheiro fica na gaveta o pb x 0 foi
útil um tabu aqui queria tentar tocar o
telefone e saí correndo
enfim essas mudanças tecnológicas foram
acontecendo naturalmente o movimento
cresceu meus filhos eu tive dois filhos
que nasceram na década de 70 ea coisa
foi indo naturalmente eu não posso me
alongar demais é e já em meus filhos na
faculdade já estava em curso
a faculdade maiores de idade portanto
quase manifestaram interesse e entra
livraria e me ajudar vocês são loucos
absolutamente longo aqui trabalha assim
muito vocês não tão a fim de se eu sei
os amigos de vocês gostam de praia no
fim de semana o outro cai no sítio que
na fazenda e eu sei como é a garotada
aqui tem que trabalhar sábado não tem
isso
não queremos ficar um ano dizendo não
para eles
há um ano eu fiquei dizendo não seja não
topa' não deixa a gente experimentar eu
fui falando não não durante um ano o
volume de trabalho pra cima de mim
cresceu enormemente
nesse meio tempo já tinha lugar do mais
uma loja porque não cabiam os livros
também muito bem no fim é acabei
concordando
já estou falando da década no início da
década de 90
meus filhos entraram e foi foi bom foi
muito bom porque eu estava
supercarregado sobrecarregado de de
trabalho e e foi foi bastante útil claro
que as divergências começam assim que
jovens muito voltados à modernidade
ligados antenados modernidade
eu fui obrigado a ceder em certas coisas
mas com alguma moderação
começa se a falar no comércio eletrônico
eu estou falando 94 eu tinha já opera do
telex e não sabem o que é isso
se alguém sabe que o telex
então é logo depois disso surgia a coisa
eletrônica através de uma coisa chamada
bbbs que durou bastante pouco bbbs é uma
sigla de bulletin board system e aí
então é foi na assim é na internet 9494
gente começa no comércio eletrônico
e foi uma coisa assim maluca toda essa
evolução tecnológica anda numa
velocidade muito maior do que o ser
humano é capaz de absorver
então foi uma uma turbulência dentro da
empresa porque tinha novas versões
diariamente quando não tinha duas vezes
por dia e passou a crescer e isso tudo
chegar os livros digitais já estou
falando
já tô falando japão em 2010 chegaram os
livros digitais com os quais a gente
trabalha ea minha sucessão já estava
desenhada ou seja sucessão da terceira
geração já estava desenhado
quando eles num determinado momento eu
vi que a coisa tava pegando no breu
senta aí vamos fazer uma coisa a partir
de vocês
a empresa deixa de ser amiga ela tem que
deixar porque acha que não
não é por uma razão muito simples eu
acho que é para a empresa familiar tem
que cessar a partir de um certo tamanho
tem que ser só a partir de um certo
tamanho a responsabilidade fica muito
grande eu estava vendo a coisa cresceu
para cima de mim
enfim fica muito grande e eu acho que a
partir de um momento cujo momento já
chegou o tamanho da empresa hoje são 2
mil funcionários
dezenove unidades um faturamento
expressivo
a gestão tem que ser profissional tudo
isso pra falar 10 deste processo de
sucessão muito bem
isso combinado assinado não tem neto que
entra não tem sobra que entra não tem
primo que entra não tem mais como fazer
isso está assinado e acordado muito bem
e fiquei pensando bom e agora eles estão
aí nós em 2005 eu fiz transformei a
limitada em s a
instalei um conselho de administração
que a partir de 2009 eu presido tem um
fundo que para que entrou ontem 25
a empresa 75% é nosso ea sucessão estava
instalada
aí eu fiquei pensando em mim e eu gozo
de saúde o moleque e meu pediatra está
super feliz comigo é então é e eu como é
que fica estava instalado o negócio e eu
aí comecei a procurar o que eu vou fazer
de mim se eu vou ficar assistindo silvio
santos o dia inteiro não bom né
a bunda na cadeira e ficar assistindo
essas coisas e comecei a procurar coisas
que eu gosto de fazer
como foi dito aqui eu presido a
sociedade cultura artística uma
sociedade centenária de são paulo que se
dedica basicamente a difusão de música
música erudita principalmente que
infelizmente em 2008 perdeu o seu teatro
keymon eu acabo de aprovar um novo
projeto uma obra de que está estimado em
140 e 150 milhões de reais 12 mil metros
quadrados que eu vou dar início muito em
breve
então não dá pra morrer de tédio
fora isso eu fui eleito diretor cultural
do ano de um clube em são paulo chamada
hebraica que eu tenho um prazer de
organizar um pouco as coisas na área
cultural faço isso o meia distância
pouca presença física e também conversei
com os diretores de uma emissora de tv
chamada arte um e eu gostaria muito de
conversar mais sobre a indústria que tão
bem conhece que a indústria do livro e
comecei a gravar um programa de tv que
começou já está no ar todo sábado às 22
horas no artigo 11 que quiserem assistir
eu converso com pessoas envolvidas na
indústria editorial autores editores e
ilustradores todos aqueles que atuam eu
não quero conversar sobre a obra de um
autor isso outros rodney silvestre e da
cor da globonews faz tão bem até menor
interesse em competir com ele
mas conversar como eu procuro um agente
literário como eu vendo meu livro tem
interesse público
a inglaterra nos estados unidos seja lá
onde for isso todo mundo desconhece
nos estados unidos saem um livro novo
imediatamente depende sair uma página
inteira no new york times é uma
indústria no brasil a gente infelizmente
não chegou nesse estágio só pra encerrar
e lembrar que suas sessões acontecem ao
longo da vida da gente
ao longo da carreira da gente se você
quer numa empresa dar um passo adiante
é interessante você achar alguém que
faça tão bem quanto você é aquilo que
você faz para que você possa subir um
degrau na sucessão da empresa familiar é
muito parecido na vida da gente a gente
faz um monte de sucessões seja na vida
privada a alguém morre alguém é
substituído descasou enfim são sucessões
todas essas são as sucessões na empresa
privada isto é mais fácil eu acho porque
o bom senso deve prevalecer
muito obrigado